good morning believe nation today's
message is have the right mindset over
to you Michael Gerber
the core business development system in
any company and every company sitting
here no matter what kind of company it
is is the generation lead conversion
client fulfillment how many people do
you attract to your door how do you
convert a larger and larger percentage
of those people to become customers and
how do you convert the largest
percentage of those customers to become
clients and the ballgame of that is
mindset it's truly the paradigm through
which you approach the building of the
systems through which leadership and
entrepreneurship becomes a reality every
single day in the company if you don't
have the right mindset you're gonna fail
as an entrepreneur your mindset is
keeping you where you are instead of
helping you get to where you could be
every time I've made a major
breakthrough in my business and in my
life it's been from changing my mindset
around something I used to tell myself
that I was too young and that I couldn't
sell and that nobody would take me
seriously and as long as I believed that
it was a self-fulfilling prophecy was
true I didn't have the confidence and
then when I realized that I could
provide value to these people value to
these customers who were three times my
age and had way more education
experience they were willing to listen
to me but it didn't happen until I
changed the story that I was telling
myself and I changed my mindset it
happened again later in my career when I
started working with big companies like
Microsoft the one of the first companies
to approach me to work on some kind of
deal to help entrepreneurs and I thought
Microsoft is coming to me holy cow what
a big deal what possible outcome could I
get for them how could I help them their
Microsoft what advice could I have for
them and and as long as I believed that
I couldn't help them then it was true I
couldn't help them but once I understood
that hey I could actually help them
they're coming to me for a reason
there's things that I know and I've
experienced that could help them do
better when I understood that I embodied
that I adopted that as my mindset I
started to have a lot more success with
brands and so your mindset is holding
you back
it's holding you where you are and if
you want
you want to reach your dreams it's not
just about doing certain things it's
about believing that those things are
possible and that happens when you
change your mindset so my question today
today is I want to know what limiting
mindsets you've had and how it's held
you back leave in the comments below I'm
gonna join the discussion thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events beso